all right so we're now getting closer
and closer to the release of the iphone
14 lineup and based on all the leaks and
rumors that we've been seeing from very
reliable sources i'm confident that tons
of people are going to be upgrading to
the iphone 14 despite still having a
lightning port in 2022 so in this video
i'm going to be going through the
various reasons why the iphone 14 pro is
going to be revolutionary while at the
same time fixing a bunch of problems
that people have with the current iphone
13 lineup leading to record amounts of
sales and a lot of happy customers so
before i get into the number one
groundbreaking feature that will get a
lot of people to upgrade i want to go
through the other very important
features first of all one of the biggest
ones that people have been asking for
for years now is a larger display with
ironically less of the features and
that's exactly what we're expecting
because this year's iphone lineup is
getting a complete revamp we've been
seeing from multiple reliable sources
over the past few months that apple will
be adding a brand new iphone 14 max
model into the lineup which is
essentially going to be a basic iphone
14 but with a larger display and since
it's not going to be packing all of the
pro features like on the 14 pro max
model we're expecting the price of this
new 14 max to be set at
899 dollars which is a huge 300 off
compared to the pro max model and
because of the larger size it's
obviously going to have a much better
battery life compared to the regular 14
so it'll be the best bang for the buck
iphone if you really care about battery
life and display quality and yes this
new iphone 14 max model does mean that
apple's mini is finally going away for
good because of lower than expected
sales over the past couple of years and
i personally think that this new max
model is gonna sell like hotcakes now
making everything even better we've had
multiple sources like shrimp apple pro
as well as others actually leak the
schematics showing off the specifics of
what we should expect pointing to
awesome details like the earpiece
speaker on the 14 pro models being three
times thinner than the current one but
the best thing that shrimp apple pro
leaked was the pill plus hole cut out on
the pro models which will finally be
replacing the notch that has stuck
around since the iphone 12 and based on
all the mock-ups done online of how it
would look as well as our own custom
renders made by renders by shailesh
which were based on shrimp's cads i
think the 14 pro models are gonna be the
most beautiful iphones we've seen in
years and the best part is that multiple
sources like ross young and mark german
totally agreed with shrimp's leaks which
basically confirms that this will be the
design that we see this year especially
since the actual display glass parts
have been leaked showing off the design
of each model which i'll get into in
just a moment and ross young even
recently released the official screen
sizes of the models showing that the 14
pro will have a slightly larger 6.12
inch display compared to 6.06 inches and
the 14 pro max will have a 6.69 inch
compared to 6.68 which means that each
one will be getting slightly taller with
slimmer bezels and we even recently
started to see aluminum mock models of
the entire iphone 14 lineup showing off
the four models as well as some major
differences on the back first of all the
camera bumps on the 14 pro models are
absolutely massive and that's because
we're expecting the biggest camera
update we've seen on the iphone ever but
before i get into that let's talk about
the lightning port situation yes at this
point we're already expecting usbc to
come next year with the iphone 15 lineup
so it might seem like everyone is going
to be holding off but that's not
actually true so let me explain why
first of all the majority of common
people don't really care about which
port comes on the iphone is usually just
the tech enthusiasts that care but
thankfully i believe that the lightning
port on the 14 pro models is actually
going to get a huge update this year
allowing it to transfer data at usb 3.0
speeds which will fix the biggest issue
people are having with the iphone 13
lineup which is of course the slow
transfer speeds so even though we're not
getting usb-c this year lightning will
at least be getting a big upgrade on the
pro models where it's going to matter
the most because of the significantly
upgraded cameras but wait the upgrades
don't stop there because we have even
more leaks concerning even better
features minshequil recently reported
that the front camera on all four of the
new iphone 14 models is gonna get an
upgrade to support auto focus and a
faster f 1.9 aperture which will give it
a few different benefits first of all
the faster f 1.9 aperture compared to
the current f 2.2 on the iphone 13
lineup means that the selfie camera will
take in quite a bit more light which
means better quality photos with less
noise especially in dim environments not
only that but the faster aperture also
increases the depth of field which
basically means that the background will
look more blurry and that will actually
help the software take better portrait
selfies with more accurate cutouts and
now the biggest differences we're
expecting are actually going to be
coming to the pro models so let's focus
on those in terms of the displays the
big difference we're expecting is that
the refresh rate will be able to go down
to 1 hertz which means that it should be
easy to support and always on display
which is what i've been asking for for
years and because we're finally ditching
the notch and getting the dual cutouts
the bezels on the pro models are going
to be thinner than ever before giving us
even more screen real estate and in
terms of performance we're expecting the
new high-end a16 chip to come to the pro
models which will be built on tsmc's 4
nanometer process being even more
efficient and more powerful and
hopefully apple gives it a better
cooling system potentially vapor chamber
cooling which apple has reportedly been
testing this year so hopefully we stop
having overheating issues while gaming
but the main revolutionary feature we're
expecting is a brand new 48 megapixel
main camera on the back which is the
main reason why the camera bumps are
absolutely massive on the pro models
compared to the regular ones and the
beauty of the 48 megapixel camera is
that it's gonna greatly increase the
quality due to using a new much larger
sensor and apple is rumored to be using
pixel binning for nighttime and dimly
lit photos to make sure it takes in the
most amount of light and because of the
48 megapixel sensor it's gonna shoot 8k
video which i think will blow away any
other ak video on the market because i
believe apple's going to be using pro
res to shoot 8k because the a15 chip
already comes with prores encoders and
decoders so the a16 will for sure as
well and the biggest worry people had
about ak video was the lack of usbc but
once again i believe the lightning port
will be getting upgraded to support
faster transfer speeds so it won't
really be that big of an issue this year
and even though this year's iphone 14
pro isn't getting a full redesign we are
still expecting it to come with titanium
instead of stainless steel which means
it could be getting a bit lighter while
also being very tough and along with all
the other upgrades we're expecting
updated specs like wi-fi 6e bluetooth
5.2 a new 5g rf chip that's more
efficient satellite connectivity better
speakers better microphones and more and
based on our own renders i believe a lot
of people are going to love the look of
the iphone 14 pro and pro max especially
if there's a chance it comes with the
new copper slash bronze color and if you
totally disagree with me and think that
it's not worth upgrading this year
because of the lack of usbc let me know
down in the comment section below but if
you enjoyed this video click the circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you